perform transformations on the movable
quadrilateral until it matches
quadrilateral ne UT quadrilateral Knute
right over here are the two figures can
grew int so we have our little tools
here but I'm actually going to do it on
my scratch pad first to think about how
we might want to transform it so the
first thing it looks like this point
right over here would correspond to
point e once we shift it over and then
maybe dilate it down and then reflect it
over so let's try to do this so the
first thing if we were to if we were to
translate translate so how much are we
going to translate by so we're going to
move to the right by one so we're going
to the X direction we're going to
increase by one and in the Y direction
we're going to go up by we're going to
go from negative 4 to 1 so we're going
to translate by 1/5 and so that's going
to put us that's going to put our figure
someplace it's going to put our figure
like this so that point is going to be
right over here everything is going to
go in the X direction by 1 and then 1 2
3 4 5 in the Y direction so this line is
going to now is going to look like is
going to look like that so 1 and then 1
2 3 4 5 is going to go right over there
so that's going to go right over right
over there
I'll try my best to draw it and then one
in the X direction and then 1 2 3 4 5 in
the Y direction so it's going to look
it's going to look something like this
or it's going to look like this right
after that transformation and now what
we could do let's see we could we could
either reflect first or we could try to
scale it down first so let's try to
scale it down let's try to dilate it so
let's dilate it dilate and let's make
our center I don't want to change this
point right over here I like it sitting
there because that seems to be the point
that it corresponds to let's put the
center there so let's put the center at
the point 5 comma 1 so the center is
going to be right over there and we
essentially want this line this line
which has length
six to be scaled down to have length
three or essentially we want this point
right over here which is six to the left
of this point we want it to be three to
the left of this point so we want it to
get half as far so we want to scale
scale by 1/2 so then that's going to get
the figure this point is going to be
over here this point which is in the X
direction or in the Y direction to away
is now going to only be one away is now
going to be one away so it's going to be
and in the ND let me make it clear in
the X direction it says that negative
three relative to five so it's eight
away so now it's all you're going to be
four away after scale of 1/2 and the y
direction it's 2 away so now it's only
going to be now it's only going to be
one away so that point is going to go
right over there and then this point or
actually actually focus on this point
right over here we're not looking up
there just yet this point right over
here in the X direction is far away and
in the Y Direction is four weig so on a
scale of 1/2 in the X direction it's not
going to be 2 away and in the Y
direction it's going to be 2 away so
it's going to be look like it's going to
look like this after the scaling and now
it looks pretty clear we just have to do
a reflection around this line we just
have to do a reflection around the line
y equals 1 reflect around the line y is
equal to 1 so let's do all of that on
this actual tool now so first I did the
translation I'm going to translate in
the X direction by 1 in the Y direction
by 5 that got me right over there and
then I wanted to dilate it down so let
me scroll down a little bit so dilate it
about the point 5 comma 1 5 comma 1 and
then by a scale of 1/2 so that scaled me
down and now I'm going to reflect over y
equals 1 so I'm going to reflect over
the line well the line y equals 1 it
goes from the point 0 I'm just picking
two points on it so goes from the point
0 1 to 1
and there we have it we've gotten to
that point now we have to answer their
question are the figures congruent well
no the first figure was much bigger than
this one in the very way that we got it
to be able to squeeze into this one is
that we dilated it down these figures
would have been congruent if all of my
transformations were just translations
reflections and rotations but I had to
dilate it I had to scale the figure
because I had to scale the figure these
figures these figures are not congruent
knew the figures are not congruent